you can't please everybody this is a
statement i hear
all the time i've been told it virtually
every day
and so my real question is why not
and here's my theory about this guys i
think because this statement has been so
adopted and accepted that i find that
people don't even
try anymore and i think that's where the
big problem is
i actually think that this is probably
the fundamental
core of why at some level i've been
successful in everything that i've done
business-wise and life-wise of course
not everything but you know what i mean
right like
globally i'm successful because i really
really try to please everybody i'm
uncomfortable
with being disliked and obviously having
a big personality
and uh and being an east coast guy and
having that flavor and that intensity
and that passion
is a little too much for some people um
more importantly
i just am confused on why people don't
try now i understand being thin skinned
you know that's just the dna thing right
or not liking it or maybe you're so big
you can't fundamentally go after
everything but
for me ego surfing you know following
your name
everywhere whether it's twitter facebook
and especially google alerts especially
in the blog
google alerts is essential not because
you want to read the press that you're
awesome
and amazingly good looking and all that
no no
not that you want to do this my friends
because
when you see something negative i highly
recommend
that you go and read it with an open
mind understanding who you are
don't lie to yourself and then
respectfully get in contact with that
person
this has been something that i've done
very often not because i think it's
brilliant or it's good marketing and all
that because it's
it's it's the right thing to do right i
mean i
love coming back and accepting and
respecting other people's opinions
even about myself does it hurt it does
you know
does it stink that not everybody really
knows who you are of course it does
but we're all putting ourselves out
there don't get it twisted
we are all now personal brands the
second you create a profile on any
social network
you are now in the game yes you are in
the game
and so i think it is imperative to um
really go out and try i mean why not
give another
another effort to another human being
give an effort to another human being
and really
try to get them to let them get to know
you right
to to come through to you know let them
see who you are let them see your heart
let them
see your soul i think the effort is
massively lacking
in our society right now and as
technology breeds all sorts of
opportunities for people to communicate
about you
i think it's more important than effort
to give a huge effort so
you can't please everybody but why not
try
i am